-Our first guest tonight
is a Golden Globe-winning
and Academy Award-nominated
actress you know best from
"Almost Famous" and "How to Lose
a Guy in 10 Days."
She stars in the second season
of the Apple TV+ series
"Truth Be Told," with new
episodes streaming on Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-You're the closest thing
I've ever had to a mother, so...
-Sweetie.
I miss him so much.
-Me too.
-I really don't like
when people lie to me.
-Please welcome back
to the show and the studio
Kate Hudson, everybody.
♪♪
Hi.
Nice to see you.
-Hi!
Good to see you.
I can't believe this.
-Right? It's nice.
It's real human beings.
-It's like -- This is my first
back in the studio --
-It's your first studio
talk show in a while.
-Yeah. Yeah. In two years.
-You were an old pro
back in the day.
Is it coming back?
Is it like riding a bike?
-Back in the day, Seth.
Yeah, no audience.
-Yeah.
-But I'm excited. This is great.
I'm excited.
-Yeah.
-How does this feel for you?
-I'm used to it now.
I worry more, to be honest,
like how it is for guests
who are used to coming out
to wild applause.
Like I now would spook I think
if there were human beings here.
-Oh, really?
-I'm going to be like, "Eww."
-But you get that excitement.
It's a little different.
-Yeah, I think when
an audience comes back,
the adrenaline will elevate.
-Yeah.
I can talk to anybody
anytime anywhere.
-Yeah. Well, the interesting
thing about it is like --
and I want to ask because you
and your brother, Ollie,
have a podcast.
-Yeah, "Sibling Revelry."
-"Sibling Revelry." And you've
been doing it for a while.
And so much of the conversations
we hear now, especially
conversations we hear between
celebrities, are podcast form.
So you are hearing
more intimate conversations
with people than we
ever did before.
So audiences are less -- People
don't notice when they're gone.
-It's true.
I also think that
actually doing a podcast
has helped me
in doing things like this.
Do you know what I mean? When
you're on the other side of it,
I just can't believe
how hard it was to get into
the rhythm of
being the interviewer,
like what the actual balance is.
And then I do all the editing
and Oliver just like --
I was going to say [bleep] off.
We'll bleep that.
[ Laughs ]
-I like that you're like,
"I'm so good at it now.
I never say things
like [bleep] off.
Just go back."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, cut, cut, no.
But Oliver just, like, leaves
and I have to edit everything.
So in the beginning,
the editing process was insane
'cause we were so, you know --
-Was it cross-talk?
Was that the biggest issue?
-Oh, cross-talk.
Just long-winded.
-Yeah.
-You know, we're not --
We're not -- I'm used to
answering the questions.
So I would go on and on for like
five minutes about something.
I'd be like,
"Just cut all of this."
-Did you ever do them in person?
Or were they always --
even before the pandemic.
-In person, we did.
And I miss doing them in person.
-Yeah.
-And we would go for hours.
It would be like 3 1/2 hours.
We'd have so much fun.
And then one time we decided to
bring wine into the equation.
And that was the last time
we did that.
I was like,
"This is a terrible idea."
-And it's a pretty cool
podcast idea.
They should know that you guys
talk to other siblings.
You talk to people
about siblings.
-We got to get you
and your sibling on.
-We'd do it in a heartbeat.
-Yeah, because it's really fun.
And you realize
it's a relationship
that people don't really talk
about a lot,
even though everyone
loves their siblings.
But it's probably the most
important relationship
that we have.
-Yeah.
-Nobody knows you
like your sibling, good or bad.
It's the most complicated
relationship
and even more than probably
your parents.
You know, there's nobody
who understands the way
you were raised
like your sibling does.
-I agree.
-And if it's a good
relationship,
it's just the most beautiful
thing you can have in your life.
And if it's a challenging
relationship,
I think what I've learned is
that people long for it.
They long to have
that sibling connection.
-So I want to ask, too,
because you have kids.
And having an important
relationship
with a sibling like you do,
I have the same.
Like now, I'm so desperate
for them to have it.
And I realize --
My sons get along really well.
But there's also a thing
as a parent,
you can't be in charge of
how they get along.
They're either going to
like each other or not.
-You just get really dark
when they're fighting.
"One day I'll be dead!"
-[ Laughs ]
-"And you'll only have
each other!"
-"You'll only have each other!"
I want to ask real quick
about -- I heard your oldest --
Bing is 10.
-Bing is 10.
-And I'm always fascinated
what kids are into.
Bing is into something that I
don't think I've heard yet.
-Oh, yeah.
-For a 10-year-old.
-Yeah, he actually loves playing
the stock market.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Which I don't know how
this happened.
-Is it like Fisher-Price
stock market or the real one?
-Oh, no, no, no,
the real stock market.
Like, he wants stocks
for his birthday.
It was a thing.
-Wow.
-Yeah. And he follows them.
He wakes up. He looks on his
apps and follows his stocks.
And he makes good money.
-Oh, he's using --
This has happened?
[ Laughter ]
You've got him --
You bought him stocks?
-Yes, he loves his stocks.
And Foot Locker is his favorite
because it really does well
apparently.
I don't really follow Foot
Locker, but Bing tells me.
-Okay.
-You know.
And then there was one day
where it kind of dipped
and he was a little worried.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's a thing with kids.
You got to teach them, like,
there's going to be dips.
[ Laughter ]
The market's going to have dips.
-It's wild, honey.
But it's really interesting
because
he's got a great math brain,
which I just can't relate to,
really, in any way.
-Same, yeah.
-I just didn't --
But he's, like, this creative
with a math brain,
which I'm sure there's
a lot of those out there.
I don't know many of them
but my son.
And so he'll go in and he'll
create and draw and drum.
And then he checks his stocks.
It's sort of like, what?
-He's a real renaissance man.
Yeah.
-I can't wait to see what
Bing Bellamy is going to do
when he gets older,
but I'm encouraging it.
I wrote on my Instagram,
I was like he'll be handling
my portfolio in like two years.
-So, another son, Ryder.
-Ryder. He's almost 18.
-Okay, so he's giving you
a hard time about --
-Everything.
-And it seems like --
We edited some stuff together
here because he gives you
a hard time about your sort of
embracing of
the wellness culture.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, and just the fact
that I Instagram
all of my products.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So he sort of makes fun.
-I guess if you had a mom who's
gonna Instagram her products,
you're making it pretty easy
for an 18-year-old.
Let's just look at
what Ryder did.
-Oh, God.
-Hi, guys.
Kate Hudson here.
I know you know me
because you follow me.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm so funny.
Today, we're going to be making
goji berry
in bloom protein shake.
It's delicious.
I give it to my kids.
They love it.
My whole family loves it.
[ Laughter ]
-There's my little comedian.
-Fairly accurate?
Is it fairly accurate?
-Yeah. It's fairly accurate.
I mean, he's also deeply funny.
Like, Ryder -- I mean, he
clearly is going to probably
follow in the footsteps of --
I would say he's probably
the funniest in our family.
So this is like
every day for me.
Nobody makes me laugh
like Ryder.
And he just constantly makes fun
of me.
-I also want to talk about
the show real quick.
-Oh, yeah.
-This is really cool.
This is season two,
Octavia Spencer,
star of it
and also the executive producer.
And so she actually --
Did she reach out to you,
for bringing you onboard?
-She did.
Also, Reese is a producer on it,
Witherspoon,
with Hello Sunshine,
so they both did.
And it was kind of -- It was
wild because I get this call.
First, it was actually Reese,
and she's like,
"What are you doing?"
And I was like,
"What do you mean?
It's a pandemic. I'm home.
I'm literally in my house."
And she's like, "Do you want to
come do this show
in about 3 1/2 weeks?"
And in my mind, I was,
like, in -- It was, like,
in the middle of everything
that was happening.
Kind of freaked me out
a little bit.
But then I was like, "I'm not
really doing anything."
And I felt like Apple's going to
have all of our backs.
If Octavia is doing it, I would
die to work with Octavia.
And then I spoke with Octavia.
I mean, I just fell madly
in love with her.
She's the greatest,
and we had a blast.
We had a real blast,
had a very close-knit family
because nobody
could do anything
but be with each other,
you know?
And it was great.
-Well, that's really cool.
Congrats on the show.
And it's just so lovely
to see you in person.
-I know.
-Thank you for making us
your first show
back in a studio.
-Oh, I'm so happy to be here.
-The second season of "Truth Be
Told" is available on Apple TV+.